president zhao
dear victor distinguished members of the
national academy of medicine
ladies and gentlemen it is an honor for
me
to address your prestigious annual event
for 50 years the national academy of
medicine has been the voice
of objective and trusted advice
for 50 years it has brought together the
best
minds of the us and the world
to obtain the best answers science can
find
and in that time the real strength of
the academy has always been its members
from renowned professors to
world-leading pioneers in their fields
from economists to epidemiologists
ceos to neurosurgeons and even nobel
prize winners
to presidential candidates this
diversity
reflects two realities that this academy
has always understood better than most
the first is that science and research
is at its best when it is applied
i learned this in different ways as a
medical academic
as a physician and later as a politician
as academics we deepen
our knowledge and specialize in our
given field
but can be frustrated when it is not
translated into clinical outcomes
as physicians we gain a better
understanding of what our patients are
going through
but we can be frustrated with the system
that cares for them
and this is why as politicians
i believe it is our duty to draw on both
scientific knowledge and lived
experience
to design policies that work
this has always been my guiding
principle throughout my career
the second reality is that health and
medicine do not
exist in isolation you
cannot understand health without
understanding
people and society economy
and environment this is nothing new
centuries ago hippocrates advised
physicians
to learn meteorology before medicine
and he was the first to speak of the
link
between disease and climate in his
essay he called on airs
waters and places
but it is only more recently that this
has become so obvious to everyone
every day we see the tragic consequences
that come with extreme weather such as
the floods
and landslides that recently hit
southern france and northern italy
all the wildfires that have ravaged
through more than
four million acres in california
we have experienced forest fires floods
and droughts before but not with this
intensity
and frequency and we have
increasingly become aware about the
links
between rising temperatures biodiversity
destruction
and infectious diseases
50 years ago when this academy was
established
only nine countries faced severe
outbreaks of dengue fever
but as temperatures soar and human
activity spreads
it is now seen in more than 100
countries
and a record number of cases were
recorded last year alone
the point is that what happens in one
part of the world
can have a deadly or devastating impact
on the health
of communities on the other side of the
globe
so there is no such thing as out of
sight
out of mind in today's world
and this is why the debate you are
holding today
is so fitting and so timely
i say this because the links between
health and climate
are as evident as the parallels in the
way
we must address them so
i would like to briefly touch on four
common priorities
in tackling global health and global
warming
these priorities drive the eu's approach
and could define the next chapter of the
transatlantic alliance
the first is the need for international
leadership and cooperation
global crisis need global solutions
and health and climate change are two
areas where europe is willing and able
to lead
and they are two areas where strong
transatlantic alliance
has the potential to make a real
difference
when i came into office one of the first
things
i did was to launch the european green
deal
the headline goal is to become the first
climate neutral continent by 2050
but behind it is also the commitment
to support others to meet their own
paris agreement
objectives similarly
when the pandemic struck there was a
clear need for global leadership and
cooperation
and this is when my friend victor zao
called me
he saw how europe could take on
the mantle and bring the world together
and that is what we did working with
civil society
the g20 who
and many many others we brought more
than
40 countries together to raise 16
billion euros
this will finance the development of
vaccines tests and treatments
for the whole world in addition
we contributed 400 million euro to the
covex facility
to ensure that safe vaccines are
available for all
whoever they are wherever they are
and whatever they can afford
so in this spirit i believe it is now
time
to revitalize global health cooperation
from the first international sanitary
conference in paris in
1850 to the almata declaration in the
1970s
there is a long tradition of the world
working together
but a new impetus is needed and
europe stands ready to lead the way
next year i will co-host the global
health summit at g20 level
with prime minister conte of italy
to draw the lessons learned from the
crisis
europe is also ready to lead efforts to
reform and strengthen the who
and i hope we can work on this
with the next u.s administration
whatever the results of the election is
my second common priority is
more effective preparedness and response
just as with mitigation adaptation
policies for climate change we must
focus on the same principles for health
the crisis exposed the lack of global
investment
in preparing for pandemics and it showed
us
the need to strengthen our capacity to
respond to epidemics
emerging diseases and chemical
biological radiological and nuclear
threats
this is a lesson that we are already
heating here in
europe we want to build a proper
european health union in which all 27
member states
prepare and respond together
we are dedicating more money than ever
to a new eu health program
we are strengthening our medical and
scientific agencies
and we will create a european body for
biomedical
advanced research and development
similar to the us
barda
the third common priority is the need
for systemic change
challenges on a global scale cannot be
fixed with a single intervention or a
silver bullet
it requires change involving government
industry researchers and all of us as
individuals
this was one of the main drivers of the
european green deal and
this is not just about cutting emissions
it is our new growth strategy
and it is a blueprint for the
transformation of our economy and
society
it will address our over consumption of
raw materials
energy water food and land use
it will look at how we live work
travel and consume it will rely on
research
innovation and digitization to create
new jobs
it is ultimately about securing the
long-term health of
our planet our economy and our people
now the fourth and final common priority
is the need to use and respect science
and here i come back to the need for
evidence-based policy making
last month i announced a new target for
europe
to reduce its emission by at least 55
percent
as compared to 1990 levels
this target was set following an
extensive
impact assessment which looked at every
sector
every region every scenario
and this robust evidence base
is the only way we can set ourselves
realistic goals
and explain to people the need the
rational and the opportunity of change
so like many of you i am concerned about
the erosion and trust
in science in some quarters we saw the
same pattern with climate skeptics
as we see now with those spreading
disinformation about vaccines treatments
or data
but sciences also making a very popular
comeback
the world has seen its true value for
policy making
and for communicating complex public
health decisions
so we must continue to stand up for
science
so science can help us find and explain
solutions to our global challenges
ladies and gentlemen our planet
and our health are the world's most
precious global common goods
and i firmly believe that
tackling climate change is the best
global health opportunity
of our generation europe is ready to
lead and
to make this the next task for the
transatlantic alliance
and this is why this academy's work is
so
vital in today's world
and this is why i was so happy to join
you today
thank you once again victor for the
invitation and thank you all
for listening